y la comunidad hispana está alcanzando
grandes cotas de influencia en la
economía la cultura y la política de los
eeuu
más de 57 millones de personas casi 1 de
cada 5 son hispanos dos tercios de ellos
originarios de méxico durante las dos
próximas décadas el crecimiento de esta
comunidad va a tener profundas
implicaciones en la gran potencia
americana y también en el resto de
latinoamérica en este vídeo te hablamos
del poder de los hispanos en los estados
unidos
en nuestros últimos vídeos comentamos
que en una fecha tan próxima como 2020
los hispanos se convertirán en la
población mayoritaria de texas este
nuevo es un fenómeno aislado de hecho y
los hispanos son ya la población
mayoritaria en california y nuevo méxico
es decir en poco más de tres años los
dos mayores economías de eeuu y casi el
25% de su producto interior bruto
corresponderá a estados de mayoría
hispana bienvenidos a todos en nuestro
país es verdad porque somos americanos
os podéis imaginar la enorme influencia
que esto conlleva estamos hablando de
estados que en su conjunto formarían la
cuarta mayor potencia económica de la
tierra además las tasas de crecimiento
de los hispanos sobre todo por su mayor
nivel de natalidad son muy importantes
desde el año 2000 el número de hispanos
ha crecido en 20 millones de personas y
se espera que las tres próximas décadas
dupliquen prácticamente la población
superando la barrera de los 100 millones
de habitantes por cierto la mayoría de
los hispanos hoy ya han nacido en los
eeuu
fenómeno ha sido de tal magnitud que los
inmigrantes latinos que han llegado a
eeuu en los últimos 50 años superan al
conjunto de inmigrantes llegados de toda
europa entre 1840 y 1920 cuando se
produjeron las grandes migraciones de
irlandeses italianos polacos etcétera
día 3 todos conocemos la misma
influencia que estas comunidades
tuvieron en la sociedad y en la historia
de eeuu así que ya podemos imaginar la
que van a tener los hispanos que menos
años han superado en número a todos
ellos nos quepa la menor duda de que en
poco tiempo veremos al primer presidente
hispano hay una comunidad que no merece
ser callada ocultada ni menospreciada la
comunidad latina le ha dado mucho eeuu
tenemos que seguir así trabajando
haciendo un mejor país y soñando con una
mejor nación para todos
rocky es el candidato que mejor
representa nuestros valores nuestro
sentir y por eso
desde el año 2000 los hispanos han
ocupado siete de cada diez puestos de
trabajo creado y como son más jóvenes
que la media y han inmigrado
precisamente para conseguir una vida
mejor sus tasas de participación laboral
son sustancialmente mayores que las del
resto de trabajadores esto es los
hispanos trabajan de media más lo que
evidentemente y un impacto positivo muy
grande sobre la actividad económica de
los eeuu por si fuese poco los hispanos
son propietarios de más de 4 millones de
negocios
y tienen cojo las tasas más altas de
emprendimiento superando incluso a la
población asiática la tendencia es tal
que la mayoría de la generación de
hispanos pertenecientes a la denominada
generación millennials afirman que en
ser emprendedores y montar empresas es
la mejor forma de prosperar como padre
me inspiran y como presidente su
valentía me ha hecho recordar que ningún
obstáculo es muy grande ningún camino
muy largo cuál es el resultado de toda
esta pujante actividad pues que los
hispanos han incrementado en los últimos
cinco años un 50 por ciento su poder de
compra hasta alcanzaron los 1,5 billones
de dólares es decir el equivalente a 1.5
veces toda la economía español y esto no
es todo se espera que para el 2020
alcancen los 2 millones de dólares por
lo que si formasen su propio país se
situarían entre las 10 mayores economías
del mundo impresionante
solo un ejemplo de todo lo que esto
significa se espera que los próximos
diez años en la próxima década los
hispanos compren en los eeuu 6 millones
de viviendas por cierto está demostrado
además y los inmigrantes favorecen las
relaciones comerciales con sus países de
origen lo que representa sin duda una
oportunidad única para las empresas
latinoamericanas y ningún país hispano
hay tanto dinero como el que mueven los
hispanos de eeuu una cosa que nunca
pensé yo el principio cuando veníamos
vendíamos 50 dólares a la semana ahora
todos deben es algo que empezó casi casi
sin querer eso que rudy en pocos años se
convierta de ambulante en todo un
exitoso empresario
más de 11 millones de latinos votaron en
2012 y se espera que para 2030 40
millones de hispanos tengan derecho a
voto en pocos años los hispanos van a
condicionar no sólo la política de
california rejas y nuevo méxico donde
van a ser el primer grupo social sino
que también van a tener una influencia
decisiva en florida nevada arizona y
colorado donde pronto superarán el 30
por ciento de la población
y también en illinois nueva york
connecticut y un largo etcétera de
estados donde superarán el 10% de hecho
greg abbott el actual gobernador de
tejas ya ha dicho que no más de dos
legislaturas de la supremacía
republicana en tejas
llegará a su fin los valores que tienen
peronistas son los valores de este país
los valores de trabajar duro los valores
de igualdad los valores que todos pueden
tener la oportunidad esos son los
valores americanos hasta ahora la
influencia política de la comunidad ha
sido relativamente pequeña porque buena
parte de sus miembros aún no tienen
derecho a voto muchos de ellos por
cierto simplemente por no haber pedido a
la ciudadanía aún teniendo derecho a
hacerlo mal o simplemente por ser
menores de edad cargo de que por la
mañana no sólo usted sino también su
familia va a estar de por acá deportada
uy qué bonito y a mí bueno pero que es
una portada del hola además como en
muchos casos los estados no y bien los
hispanos no están en juego su abstención
ha sido tradicionalmente muy alta aún
así en 2008 y en 2012 el voto latino
tuvo una influencia clave en la elección
de vamos
y son ya muchos los analistas que
consideran que es prácticamente
imposible ganar las elecciones si el
apoyo hispanos no es de al menos el 40
por ciento además está infraponderación
en el poder político va a cambiar pronto
y precisamente candidatos como donald
trump pueden favorecer decididamente
esta evolución y le quiero decir a marco
rubio ponte las pilas de bus ponte las
pilas y lv clinton ponte las pilas
porque todo lo loco es ser presidente
y los republicanos ya cometieron el
mismo error en california en 1994 cuando
el gobernador [ __ ] wilson lanzó una dura
política anti inmigración con la vista
puesta en la presidencia su iniciativa
conocida como la propuesta 187 se
envolvió en una dura retórica
antihispana y llegaba a negar cualquier
servicio público a los inmigrantes sin
papeles incluyendo servicios sanitarios
vitales
durante la campaña se acusó a los
hispanos de invadir california delinquir
y quedarse con los puestos de trabajo o
suena el resultado es que wilson ganó y
aprobó la controvertida propuesta pero
al mismo tiempo aquella campaña despertó
el poder electoral de los latinos se
crearon redes de influencia campañas
para animar a votar plataformas sociales
y desde aquel momento el partido
republicano quedó completamente
destruido en el estado la tierra de
richard nixon y ronald reagan que hoy es
un estado monocolor en favor del partido
demócrata
pero el caldo de cultivo sembrado por
líderes como tras estar que según un
estudio del pew research center's el 58
por ciento de los votantes republicanos
consideran que los inmigrantes hispanos
son una amenaza para el futuro de los
eeuu esto además de ser una falacia es
como querer poner puertas al mar lo
cierto es quiere seguir esta tónica lo
pagarán muy caro
yo hablo por toda la gente mexicana
cuando digo que puedes tomar tus
insultos y meterte lo es por tu gran d y
estúpido qué pensáis vosotros creéis que
campañas como las de tram unirán y
movilizaron a los hispanos creéis que
pronto veremos al primer presidente
latino en la casa blanca espero que os
haya gustado este vídeo si ha sido así
no dudéis en suscribiros al canal
recordar que como dice alberto es gratis
y mandando nuestras opiniones un saludo
y hasta la próxima